♪ ♪
>> Hannity: DEMOCRATS ARE IN
MOST DISARRAY IS EVER ANOTHER
BATCH OF REALLY BAD POLLS FOR
THE IMPLODING JOE BIDEN IT WILL
DOWN WITH FOX NATION OUR FRIEND
PIERS MORGAN AND ASK ABOUT HIM
WALKING OFF GOOD MORNING BRITAIN
LAST YEAR WILL GET MORE REACTION
TO HIS RECENT INTERVIEW WITH THE
45TH PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP A
LOT OF DRAMA AND PEERS LIFE
LATELY IS A SMALL SAMPLE TAKE A
LOOK.
>> THE MOST EXPLOSIVE INTERVIEW
OF THE YEAR.
>> LET'S FINISH UP THE
INTERVIEW.
>> LET'S TURN THE CAMERA OFF.
>> THE ROYAL FAMILY ACCUSED PHIL
THINGS THING'S BE AT LEAST A
HUNDRED.
>> CANNOT CALL HER THE OLD BAG.
IF YOU CONTINUE TO TRANSFER.
>> SORRY NO.
SORRY NO CAN DO THIS.
>> BUT FIRST A NIGHT BILLIONAIRE
CEO AND INNOVATOR ELON MUSK HAS
NOW STRUCK A $44 BILLION DEAL TO
ACQUIRE TWITTER AND IS IN A TAKE
IT PRIVATE SINGLING A RETURN
HOPEFULLY TO FREE SPEECH
PRINCIPLES TO THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM INCLUDING A WHOLE HOST
OF REFORMS TO MAKE TWITTER MORE
TRANSPARENT MORE ACCOUNTABLE AND
MORE COMMITTED TO FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION NOW ELON MUSK IT SAID
TODAY IN A STATEMENT QUOTE,
FREE SPEECH IS THE BETTER WALK
OF A FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY AND
TWITTER IS A DIGITAL TOWN SQUARE
WILL MATTERS VITAL TO THE FUTURE
OF HUMANITY ARE DEBATED I ALSO
MAKE TWITTER BETTER THAN EVER BY
ENHANCING THE PRODUCT WITH MORE
FEATURES, NEW FEATURES MAKE IN
THE ALGORITHMS OPEN SOURCE TO
INCREASE TRUST DEFEATING THE
SPAMBOTS AND AUTHENTICATING ALL
HUMANS.
>> Hannity: TWITTER HAS
TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND COMMUNITY OF
LOSERS TO UNLOCK IT AND I'VE
BEEN SAYING THIS FOR YEARS THAT
PEOPLE SHOULD BE FREE TO SAY
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO SAY AND
FREE TO DISCUSS A WIDE RANGE OF
TOPICS IN POLITICAL VIEWS
WITHOUT JUST BEING SHUT DOWN
SILENCED AND CANCELED JUST
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FIT FIT
THEREFORE LEFT NARRATIVE.
AND THIS BY THE WAY GOES FOR ALL
THE BIG TECH THAT'S FACEBOOK,
GOOGLE, TWITTER.
PRETTY MUCH ALL OF THEM THE OF
ALL OTHER COMPANIES TO GO INTO
ONE BIG LEFT-WING ECHO CHAMBER
ONE BIG ARM OF THE DEMOCRATIC
RADICAL SOCIALIST PARTY SO
ELON MUSK'S DECISION SHOULD BE
WELCOME NEWS TO PRETTY MUCH
EVERYONE OTHER THAN THE FAR LEFT
VOICES WHO APPEAR HELL-BENT ON
CENSORSHIP AND CANCELING TO HELP
DO THE BENDING OF THE DEMOCRATS
AND PROTECT JOE BIDEN AT ALL
COSTS.
THE MELTDOWN BY THE WAY IT IS
UNDERWAY DIDN'T TAKE LONG FAR
LEFT COLUMNISTS JENNIFER RUBIN
TWEETING ELON MUSK IS THE ANSWER
TO THE JEOPARDY QUESTION WHAT IS
THE ONE WAY TO MAKE TWITTER
WORSE?
ACTIVIST SHAWN KING TOOK IT STEP
FURTHER SAYING THAT ELON MUSK
WANTED TO PURCHASE TWITTER SON
ABOUT LEFT VERSUS RIGHT IT'S
ABOUT WHITE POWER AND THE REST
THE MEDIA MOB WILL ARE TERRIFIED
OF ELON MUSK EMBRACING SOMETHING
CALLED FREEDOM OF SPEECH THAT WE
CHERISH THAT TAKE A LOOK.
>> ONE OF THE RICHEST GUYS IN
THE WORLD TO GO FOR SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM -- IS NOT A WINNING
FORMULA TO ME.
IT REMINDS OF AN OLD BOND MOVIE
WERE DR. EVIL AND GUYS LIKE THAT
GOLDFINGER AND SICK OF THE MEDIA
I JUST SUMMING TO TELL PEOPLE TO
SOME IS IS NOT GREAT ABOUT THIS.
>> HOW WILL THIS CHANGE OUR
LIVES AND WHEN HE'S OPEN IT UP
TO FREE SPEECH DOES NOT ALLOW
MORE MISINFORMATION ON THE
PLATFORM?
>> IF YOU GET INVITED TO SUMMING
WHERE THERE'S NO RULES IN TOTAL
FREEDOM FOR EVERYONE TO ACTUALLY
GO TO THE PARTY OR UNIT DECIDE
TO HOME?
>> DOES THE WEIRD GUY AND IT'S A
BIG.
>> I'M CONFUSED OF WHAT TO DO.
WE ALL USE TWITTER DO I STOP TO
IT WAIT AND WHAT HAPPENS?
>> Hannity: IT WAS THE MOB WHO
TEAMED UP WITH TWITTER TO CENSOR
THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP STORY
AND THEY FALSELY CALLED IT
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION AND WAS
HAD RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION ALL
THE RUMPS OF THOUSAND 20
ELECTION ALL IN AN EFFORT TO
FUEL YET ANOTHER HOAX TO PROTECT
DEMOCRATS AND IS ALWAYS ATTACKED
DONALD TRUMP.
BUT OF COURSE THE LAPTOP GUESS
WHAT.
IT WAS AUTHENTIC ALL ALONG AND
REVEALED DAMNING EVIDENCE OF HOW
THE JOE BIDEN FAMILY SYNDICATE
USE THEIR POLITICAL STATUS TO
ENRICH THEMSELVES AS A FAMILY
AND TO DO INK LUCRATIVE DEALS
WITH FOREIGN ADVERSARIES LIKE IN
RUSSIA AND CHINA AND UKRAINE AND
ALL THE COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
AND GET THIS WERE LEARNING EVEN
MORE ABOUT PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN'S
LIFE THEY NEVER MET WITH TALK
WITH HUNTER BUT ANY FOREIGN
FAMILY BUSINESS DEALINGS BECAUSE
ACCORDING TO VISITOR LOGS FROM
THE OBAMA-BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
VIEWED BY "THE NEW YORK POST"
HUNTER BIDEN'S CLOSEST BUSINESS
PARTNER ERIC SURE WHEN GUESS
WHAT HE MADE AT LEAST 19 VISITS
TO THE WHITE HOUSE OF THEIR
OFFICIAL LOCATIONS BETWEEN 2,009
AND 2015.
SO TONIGHT COUNTRY OUGHT TO BE
ASKING ALL ASK IT WHAT IT
JOE BIDEN KNOW AND WHEN DID HE
KNOW IT?
DOES HE STILL STAND BY THE LIE
THEY NEVER TALK TO US ON HUNTER
ABOUT HIS FOREIGN BUSINESS
DEALS?
AND THAT'S NOT ALL.
ACCORDING TO CATHERINE ENCOURAGE
HER FORMER COLLEAGUE NOTE CBS
NEWS PROSECUTORS HAVE SUBPOENAED
PATERNITY RECORDS INCLUDING TAX
DOCUMENTS FOR THE 2019 LAWSUIT
THAT WAS FILED BY LONDON ROBERTS
AND ARKANSAS WOMAN WHO HAD A
CHILD WITH HUNTER AND ACCORDING
TO A 2018 EMAIL TO HIS BROTHER'S
WIDOW HUNTER PRESSURED HALEY
BIDEN TO GETTING AN HIV TEST
WITH THE EMAIL ENTITLED QUOTE
YOU NEED TO GET TESTED FOR HIV
ALLEY.
IF YOU RECALL HUNTER WAS
REPORTEDLY HAVING AN AFFAIR WITH
HALLE ABOUT A YEAR AFTER HIS
BROTHER DIED AND BEFORE THE
RELATIONSHIP APPARENTLY
DETERIORATED.
BUT DON'T FORGET THAT THE LAPTOP
STORY ISN'T JUST A STORY ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN AND HIS DESTRUCTIVE
BEHAVIOR.
THAT STORY IS MORE ABOUT
JOE BIDEN AND THE JOE BIDEN
FAMILY AND ABOUT THE MEDIA MOB
AND ABOUT BIG TECH IN THIS
COUNTRY AND HOW THEY COLLUDED TO
COVER UP ANY AND ALL EVIDENCE OF
THE JOE BIDEN FAMILY AND THE
VARIOUS FOREIGN DEALINGS AND
JOE'S LIES ABOUT NOT KNOWING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
IT WAS A BIG SELECTION COVER UP
IN MODERN HISTORY.
I WAS IMMEDIATE DONE THEIR JOB
AND ACTUALLY INDEBTED THE LAPTOP
HOW THEY ACTUALLY MADE THE RIGHT
DECISION A YEAR AND A HALF LATER
BUT WHEN IT MATTERED BEFORE THE
ELECTION I COULD'VE HAD AN
IMPACT ON THE ELECTION?
WE'LL LET YOU MAKE THAT
DECISION.
I THINK HE COULD'VE.
THAT'S WHY SO MANY ON THE LEFT
ARE SO HELL-BENT ON CENSORING
CONSERVATIVES AND CENSORING
STORIES THAT ARE BAD FOR
DEMOCRATS AND THAT'S WHY THEY
ARE INCOMPLETE PANIC MODE OVER
ELON MUSK AND HIS COMMITMENT TO
FREEDOM OF SPEECH ABOUT LIBERALS
BELIEVED IN FREEDOM OF SPEECH I
THOUGHT THEY LOVE A GUY LIKE
ELON MUSK.
HERE'S A GUY MAKE ELE